- I've been told that I'm
very like bootylicious.
So I'm just worried that it's a look
that I won't be able
to find anywhere else.
And this might turn into a habit.
(energetic piano music)
- I hear they are comfortable.
- They're attractive, I guess?
I don't know.
- Leggings make me thirsty.
As the kids say.
- So these are more of
your standard jegging.
- These are really nice.
- These scream my name.
- Good thing I wore underwear.
- I'm not prepared for this video.
Which is why I'm wearing
robot boxers today.
Please don't show that.
- The pants of the past,
get outta here.
Here we go.
These are really colorful.
- Oh (laughing) like a freaking glove.
- Now it just feels like
I'm getting into a leotard.
- Is that kinda the leggings move?
Do girls do this move in
private to get these things on?
- This is ridiculous.
This is ridiculous.
- My penis is doing the
division sign right now.
I got a testicle here and a testicle here.
It is tight!
- What?!
- I think this is my new style.
Who needs jeans?
This is much better.
- I shouldn't be wearing boxers.
I think these are like, you
wear a thong with these, right?
- I look like a chicken.
- I feel like a Gisele!
Or a gazelle.
Gisele is Tom Brady's wife.
I guess I feel like her too.
- I feel like I can kick really well.
(grunts)
- That's pretty good.
- They're warmer than I expected.
They are really sealing the flavor.
- I feel like a really
weird Superman right now.
- This is like what Spiderman wears.
Spiderman wasn't even
into like fighting crime,
he just wanted to wear
this and be comfortable.
- These are tight!
I feel athletic.
- I wish it was socially acceptable
for guys to just wear this.
- I'd say, you know, go for it.
If you really like how these feel on you,
as a guy, or if you identify as a guy,
then I say go for it.
(electric guitar music)